bueno muy buenas tardes cómo les va todo
bien
me encantó tienen energía me hicieron
sentirme vamos a hacer algo tengo una
idea vamos a arrancar de vuelta con esto
porque me demoré un poquito también en
subir hito yo voy a salir voy a volver a
entrar pero ya entra de una forma un
poquito más fuerte con un poco de música
pero citó en su colaboración también si
viene citar que todos ustedes cuando yo
me paré acá en el medio de vuelta hagan
mucho ruido aplausos silbidos gritos
quiero escucharlos a todos y liberen se
relajen se quiere escuchar sonido de
todo tipo pero lo que sea que quiero
escuchar ruido necesito que se expresen
disculpa que cuesta un hombre un gestas
hay derecho acá fernando fernando va a
ser confort fernando cuando yo entré y
me pare acaso el x de vuelta me grita
genio
pero fue genio si es una paga que me
hace sentir muy bien
muchas gracias bien necesito alguien más
usted el caballero que estoy como es un
hombre agustín agustín para que él me
dio vuelta más sanitario lo ha seguido
lo conociste acá pidió lo más grande de
todo el mundo el que siempre quisiste el
picacho cualquiera así un ídolo
y necesito uno más uno más usted es
joven como es un hombre nicolas cuando
entre el móvil y carl genio el
mayoritario logos ni comas a gritar te
amo está bien
el resto lo de silva grita y esto es
tremendo yo voy a bajar
vas a alargar la música vuelo entre esto
explota no vas a poder creer tremendos
valerón en escuchar aplausos silbidos
gritos así
gracias yo también me encanta que lindo
muchas gracias
muchas gracias qué lindo qué lindo
arrancar este texas y con esa energía
con ese entusiasmo con un público
presente como ustedes así tan espontáneo
no
pero ahora voy a presentar con todos
ustedes yo soy el mago gonzalo me han
invitado para estar aquí un poquito
compartirles un poco de magia
pero bueno vamos a arrancar con todo
esto mi presentación fue algo floja así
que les traje algo dijeron vas a venir
acá y vas a tener que hacer algo para la
gente así que tras esto para explicarles
lo que voy a hacer ustedes se
preguntarán por qué un mago viene con
dos tenedores es muy sencillo es porque
durante los próximos minutos voy a hacer
el entretenedor
para que tengo peores
si quieren les puedo dar un abrazo con
tenedor
bueno es un chiste malo pero me siento
cubierto en fin vamos vamos a arrancar
con este show de magia sí y me gustaría
empezar con uno de los efectos más
antiguos que tiene la magia conocido
mundialmente como el gran misterio de
los aros chinos muchos magos hacen este
efecto donde unos anillos de metal se
enganchan y se separan sin explicación
aparente muchos lo hacen pero ninguno
sabe el porqué del nombre porque se
llama el gran misterio de los aros
chinos yo sí he investigado mucho me
metí en wikipedia en tren por inga y
descubrí que se llama el gran misterio
de los aros chinos por una simple razón
son aros son chinos y es un misterio si
no pase tanto tiempo en wikipedia
pero me gustaría compartirlo con ustedes
vamos a hacer con algo de música y
arrancamos ahí
[Aplausos]
[Música]
y
tú mismo
d
[Música]
muchas gracias
bueno espero que la estén pasando bien
que se está invirtiendo están pasando
lindos que bueno se les va a pasar
enseguida no sea un problema pero bueno
esto se trata de estar creando
realidades la magia se trata mucho de ir
creando realidades viendo cosas
diferentes por ejemplo cada uno tiene
una perspectiva diferente un mismo
objeto en que usted queda acá
concentrado concentrado
un pañuelo muy bien sí
hay que estar muy atentos porque las
cosas cambian se transforman y en un
segundo todo puede dejar de ser lo que
era si eso es lo que tiene la magia es
es curioso es curioso como las
perspectivas cambian y me gusta estar
rodeado de todos ustedes porque veo que
son gente muy creativa que tienen
distintas visiones de las mismas cosas
voy a sacar un objeto ya necesitar su
participación en este momento y quiero
que vean qué es esto que tengo aquí en
mi mano levanten la mano algunos que
tenga ganas de participar que mira que
tengo acá hay que colaboradores que eso
me encanta
bueno empiezo yo empiezo yo un punto
rojo en un cuadrado blanco que alguien
con creatividad que puedes llegar a
hacer esto la bandera de japón muy bien
me encanta me encantó vengan a alguien
más que tengo un hija sea en el fondo
la cara de un dado me gustó mucho me
gustó mucho seguro pasa mucho tiempo al
casting oh eso es
es bueno tampoco en exceso no tanto pero
es bueno si mi tía por ejemplo mi tía
antes vivía en el casino ahora no va más
a ustedes se ríen pero me tocó una
familia muy apostador a mi tío para
navidad se sacó el gordo para ti en la
mano así
pero aún así es verdad tener razón es un
dado es un dato muy pero muy buena tu
visión de esto porque solamente tiene
dos lados los dedos tienen muchas caras
esto solamente tiene el uno y tiene el
dos si sería imposible que tuviera el
tres y más difícil aunque tuviera el
cuatro eso no va a pasar porque tiene
dos lados nada más
le voy a explicar lo explica
[Aplausos]
me pidieron que explique el
funcionamiento de un efecto mágico le
voy a explicar cómo funciona esto cuando
llego que tengo un punto en realidad no
tengo un punto sino que tengo 2
entonces si está para acá parece que hay
una cita para acá parece que hay tres es
muy fácil lo mismo sucede del otro lado
yo voy a dar vuelta y digo que tengo dos
puntos si tapo parece que hay dos pero
si está boca parece que hay cuatro
porque hay tres cds
ahora es muy sencillo cómo hacemos para
hacer este efecto de magia caballero
usted que está delante no es un hombre
arístides aris tiene me encanta sencillo
de recordar a arístide
supongamos que un día se levanta
temprano así lo que nunca sale a la
calle se levanta temprano de un papel en
el piso que se aprenda magia se anoten
el curso tres meses se recibe de mago
está acá arriba arístide sí y aprende
cómo se hace este efecto mágico que
necesito para esto muy sencillo una
cartulina de color blanca primero y
principal donde sacamos una cartulina
blanca señorita muy bien método clásico
de la librería la compra de los segundos
que necesitamos es pegarle dibujarle
pintarle tres puntos de un lado dos del
otro y esto arístides lo guardamos
adentro del maletín arístides tiene
maletín
hay que conseguir una lista de pueblos
no se puede llegamos nos presentamos yo
soy el mago gonzalo fáciles de recordar
con sã lo a ver ustedes
las mujeres
los varones
las viejas
ninguna se presenta a arístide igual
perfecto sea y saca está entre el
maletín importante aristy decir con las
dos manos al mismo tiempo dentro del
maletín ustedes se preguntarán por qué
porque el cerebro del ser humano no
puede ser más de una actividad a la vez
no así por ejemplo arístides el cangrejo
que es más inteligente y más veloz de
mente que el ser humano pero en un
cangrejo a casi que no nos importaría
bien sacamos esto el maletín importante
sacarlo tapando acá supongamos que hay
un cangrejo arístide haga cangrejo no
habla así que no importa bien decimos
que tenemos un punto importante que no
se ve
pone elegir un cangrejo y que hablara
quién le va a creer un cangrejo el coso
ahí que había costado no es creíble bien
para afectar este decimos que tenemos un
punto importante no levantar la mano sí
pues si no la gente sea cuenta estamos
haciendo trampa razón a la gente deduce
no es tonta sí haré la parte difícil de
la escena es tapar después girar está
para después ir a tapar después muy bien
por este tema que el serio del ser
humano el cangrejo siguen cerebro no no
explicar de vuelta bien tapar después
girar que la gente no vea que está el
punto vamos con lo difícil en realidad
la parte complicada es mostrar el 3
porque acá abajo de la mano no hay
puntos y la gente ve que no esté el
punto del 3 se van a dar cuenta que
estamos haciendo trampas y arístides me
sigas taca perfecto lo mismo pasa cuando
mostramos el 4 si la gente de que hay
abajo esa mano no hay punto se dan
cuenta que estamos haciendo trampa ahora
supongamos que hay un cangrejo en la
sala no que ese registro vino de artex
dos sentados en el fondo y grita porque
habla el vino dice arístides
está tapando ahí donde no hay ningún
punto
en el costal gang
lo miramos al cangrejo cangrejo nos mira
se produce un rayo de tensión que cruza
de lado a lado la punta punta a punta la
sala dice ojalá que los japoneses te
conviertan en kanikama cangrejo
chequeamos los dedos le mostramos el 5
supongamos que el cangrejo sigue dudando
nuestra habilidad mágica chequeamos una
vez más y le mostramos el 6 ahora sí si
el cangrejo de 6 puntos acá lo mandamos
al oculista porque no está viendo nada
bien muchas
[Música]
como ánimo venimos bien de tiempo
estamos bien perfecto bien voy a citar
en este momento de una persona que pase
a compartir conmigo el escenario
necesito dos personas en realidad
alguien que quiera venir sino bajo y
busco no tengo ningún problema dos
personas que quieran venir a ayudarme un
segundo bien perfecto no pasa nada
vas a venir vos que estás ahí perfecto
muchas gracias
bien y necesito alguien más alguien más
alguien más usted señorita de rojo
si usted acérquese perfecto cómo estás
gaby
estefanía perfecto
y estefanía usted no me van a ayudar con
algo tengo por acá dentro del maletín o
del objeto que usan los magos comúnmente
este sí
ahora han visto alguna vez su nuevo
hacer magia con cartas si yo los voy a
usar el día de hoy pero de usar como
objeto así que no importa si no conocen
las cartas de póker lo que sí es
importante que sepan contar hasta 10
bien 78
gaby
tiene las cartas haciendo mal el gaby te
explico lo que vas a hacer vas a agarrar
y vas a contar 10 cartas en mi mano
de 11 a 21 muy bien voy a contar 10
cartas y ella va a contar 10 cartas en
mi mano y después que ya termine que
desconfíe pero como no me de hoy a 1 2 3
4 5 6 7 8 9 10 perfecto no sé qué pasó
después además de culpa mía ya te vas a
pasar las cartas de estefanía y estas 10
cartas gabi trabas aborden un lugar al
que yo no tenga acceso está bien
vamos a cantar dejarlos en manos también
estefanía 123456789 desperfectos ya
estábamos canchero iguales a que la
vista encima por un tema de noche no te
mires a deja la ponía dentro del maletín
y estas diez cartas las vas a dejar
también en un lugar al que yo no tenga
acceso
bien me gustó mucho
lo que vamos a hacer ahora es intentar
jugar un poco con la imaginación y con
la realidad vamos a intentar doblar la
realidad yo ya retirar cartas donde
están guardadas de estefanía de las de
gabi perdón y las voy a pasar a donde
están las de estefanía
tranquila léase de forma invisible no te
preocupes
voy a tomar la primera carta si gavi
tengo acá una carta en mi mano la vez
no importa stefani a atención voy a
retirar por él iba a llegar a donde
estaba el aire llegó sentiste que llegó
tremendo y ya vamos con la segunda
segunda carta que sacó la tengo acá en
mi mano
gaby la vez
no
import
el interior de la carta girada por el
aire sea sentiste que sigo en esto
es muy bueno todo esto me encanta última
vez que voy a hacer tercera vez la
tercera es la vencida dijo el chino y lo
puso de vuelta en la góndola bien bah
saco la tercera carta a la vez
dios te conserve la vista bien
esta va a ser más complicado ya la idea
se respalde a la tiró hoy me pase rebota
contra el maletín vuelve sigo sentiste
que llegó
vamos a ver si esto ha funcionado así a
surtir efecto tenían 10 cartas a su voz
10 cartas quiero que saquen las tuyas
tenía 10 cartas te saqué tres de las
cuales ninguna viste hubo nada no
importa cuántas tendrían que quedar
tesis a que 37 quiero que cuentes de una
una en mi mano y veamos si funciona una
dos tres cuatro cinco seis
no quiero ninguna y de bolsillo tremendo
vamos como estefanía tenías 10 cartas
sumamos 3 tendrían que quedarte 13 claro
que sí quiero que contemos todos juntos
ahora creo de mayo en vamos 1 2 3 4 5 6
7 8 9 10 11 12 13 cartas fuerte el
aplauso para dos señoritas muchas
gracias pueden volver a su lugar
[Aplausos]
[Música]
bien
y ya me acerco a la parte final de
presentación necesitar de un caballero
más que me ayude que colabore joven
usted como es un hombre si julián
cuántos años tenés julián perfecto julio
venía cerca del escenario
fuerte aplauso para julián
[Aplausos]
cómo está julián alguna vez has vivido
magia muy de cerca no bien vamos a
intentar algo para necesito saber si es
una persona impresionable o no me voy a
tapar la mano rápido julián un juguete
en el rápido rápido rápido juguete en
era rápido rápido un juguete en era
décimo un juguete en era rápido a ver
qué cosa ahora que es una barbie
tremendo
muy bueno
por acá en serio necesito saber si de
verdad es una persona impresionable te
impresiona fácil sí sí yo me arranco el
dedo gusta sus tareas
vamos a probar una dos tres
en el chiste
julián te noto como una persona de mundo
un tipo conocedor de la vida un viajante
un hombre ducho estudioso tengo un
objeto que en mi mano creo que me has
que es esto julián
enfocado julián a qué es esto
agua
un sobre julian si uso que puede haber
dentro de este sobre escucha
monedas me dice vamos a ver no
sabes que se esto julián
un cascanueces no haber ahí
la arquitectura
suena esposa julián
sabe que son las esposas norteamericanas
las que se casan con norteamericano
estas son japonesas
van en los dedos pulgares de las manos
me gustaría que atrás pero de julián por
favor pulgares
julián cerramos un lado el juli se puede
salir de ahí
son esposas son para eso obviamente no
se puede julián tranquilo te voy a
liberar extra na más para que veas que
no se podía salir
romy la llave que abría donde quedo
en un cerrajero hoy viernes algunos
chicos de saber relájate julia relájate
botía libera tranquilo estará más que
nada para que compruebes que no se
podían abrir sino la cola ya tenías en
tu mano te explico por qué voy a hacer
en este momento un pequeño acto de
telepatía julián que no es un televisor
para alarma de tu papá es otra cosa si
tengo que otro sobre exactamente igual
al anterior con llaves colgando que
tiene adentro julián te vieron a pista
no es una sandía
mi esposa me dice vamos a ver claro que
sí fuerte el aplauso para julia muy bien
julián
julián tengo dos esposas aquí qué
significan estos juli para nóminas una
esta va a ser para mí y la otra va a ser
para vos cuál va a ser para mí cuál va a
ser para vos cuándo hacer para mí cuál
va a ser para esta para quién lo siento
pero tengo que dar esta nueva mentira
juli la que vos quieras para vos creés
esa cresta está perfecto esa queda para
vos entonces te vamos a colocar en tus
dedos muy bien a esta cerramos el lado a
cerramos el lado de juli muy bien estás
cómodo tranquilo relajado bien porque
espectadores en este momento ustedes van
a ver uno de los milagros más bonitos
que tenemos que mirando al frente voy a
tapar las manos
y a recordarlo a houdini
escucha van a ver un hermoso efecto en
el cual tus dedos van a cambiar de color
se van a poner morados
se van a poner negro se van a salir te
vas a sacar las de postre menos no te
gusto en importar en pretoria escuchame
te sentís cómodo que estás tranquilo
está nervioso tranquilo ese es mi pollo
no mentira este mi pollo mira
ustedes se ríen pero así como en este
pollo fue paquita de suya
pero la tiene la suya lúdica la
brasilera la policía que dice cicatriz
es tremendo la infancia momento de
éxtasis total es tu momento ernesto no
me falles es para hilar el área
[Risas]
era lo mejorcito del show julián escucha
como os dije dos esposas en juego y
ahora viene un momento en que algunos se
van a reír y nosotros no julián me la
tenés que poner para
debajo
no sé por qué nos gustan
ahí está julio muchas gracias
julián párate de este lado eso
perfectamente así un poquito más al
frente está junto a la escucha
vamos a intentar librarnos de esto julio
si escucho este hablar de una película
que se llama las 50 sombras de gray te
imaginarás cómo sigue esto escucha cura
más estirado hacia delante basar los
brazos lo hasta levantar hacia arriba
vas a mantener ahí porque yo voy a pasar
en este momento por delante de julián y
julián bueno
tranquilos vayan tranquilos
julia y de manera que yo salga esto
puede salir por arriba
no puedo salir por abajo
por donde quieres que salga por arriba
por favor
lo lamento pero tengo que salir por
abajo
tranquilo julián soy un profesional
por fin se me dio
julián se levanta algo hay te golpeó
escucha
julián más de levantar esta pierna muy
bien brazos estirados hacia delante
luego bajando despacito despacito
despacito despacito no tan despacito
parecemos dos pavos abrazo julián
escucha no está cerrado siempre a la
fracasa bien el plan b el plan b suele
tener menos porcentaje de fallo dice que
yo estoy pasar por delante tuyo vamos a
pasar la cabeza por el agujero y ya lo
tengo de vuelta
en el plan está cómodo
bueno
como también el plan del plan si no
falla nunca hablemos todo para atrás
todo para atrás
julián antes de venir a que esto esté
viendo alguna vida alcohólica algún
destilado de alcohol cerveza vino no
puedes hacer esto
qué habilidad lo que tienes que hacer es
agachar el cuerpo y pasar el pie por el
agujero el pie por el agujero el pie
hojas al piso y ya estamos libres pero
no acá seguridad sos un asco
escucha vamos a hacer algo tranquilo
relájate
no vamos a liberar julián presta
atención muy a tapar las manos con el
pañuelo sin tapar las manos voy a contar
hasta 3 123 voy a liberar tremendo losa
porque él me ama
para eso
ay está costando más de lo que
esperábamos hacer aparecer la llave la
llave va a aparecer en un lugar místico
maravilloso no hasta poder crear haya
usted caballero con su nombre voz si
leonardo la llave aparece el bolsillo
leonardo revise el bolsillo el bolsillo
el bolsillo trasero del pantalón leo el
de atrás del pantalón
está la llave leonardo
no si estaba nos callamos de trastes o
inclusive
julián porque en realidad yo mis esposas
nunca las tuve puestas ahora sí
llegó el momento del arte voz voy a
buscar la llave que la tengo que hacer
que te ponga de costadito agáchate un
poco
levanta la cola
y quédate quieto a ver si no le soltamos
el lado ha soltado se le ve fuerte el
aplauso para julia muchísimas gracias
julián un placer se disfrutando
[Música]
[Aplausos]
muchísimas gracias así me despido los
dejo que sigan disfrutando de gente que
tiene cosas importantes que decir no
como yo espero que la pasen bien el
resto de la jornada yo soy el mago
gonzalo y nos veremos la próxima chau
hasta luego